next Michael mandelbaum talks about the
ideas that conquered the world peace
democracy and free markets in the 21st
century he lays out what he believes are
the dominant global ideas in the
post-cold war era mr. Mandelbaum is a
foreign policy professor at Johns
Hopkins School of Advanced International
Studies this is an hour the purpose of
this book is to provide a context into
which to fit the disparate events from
terrorism to globalization from Chinese
succession politics to Argentine
economic crises that pass before us on
the pages of our newspapers and on
television every day this book offers a
framework an overview the subject of the
ideas that conquered the world is the
big picture now we had such a framework
during the Cold War and that framework
was the Cold War itself for most of the
second half of the 20th century
virtually everything that happened in
the world either derived from or could
be related to the great global struggle
between east and west and then the Cold
War ended and our framework collapsed
the purpose of this book is to offer a
replacement for the Cold War not the
Cold War as an event but the cold war as
a context for international affairs and
the replacement that I propose is the
supremacy of three great ideas peace as
a method of organizing international
relations democracy as the optimal form
of government and the free market as the
best way to structure economic life the
theme of this book is that the central
fact of the 21st century is the triumph
of our liberal ideas now that thesis
baldly stated immediately requires at
least three qualifications first the
word triumph requires qualification for
not all three of these ideas
or practiced everywhere the world is
certainly not wholly peaceful or
entirely democratic although the free
market is pretty close to being a
universal institution these days what do
I mean by the triumph of these ideas
well what I mean is that now for the
first time since they were introduced in
the second half of the 18th century they
have no serious rivals as formats for
organizing social political and economic
life the status that i impute to peace
democracy and free markets in the 21st
century is captured by a story I tell in
the book about a French architect who
was asked where in Paris he would most
like to live he replied the Eiffel Tower
on the grounds that this was the only
place in the city where he wouldn't have
to look at it well that story raises two
points that are germane to this book
first the story represents an important
feature of the book which is that it is
written to be reader friendly it
reflects my conviction that serious
books about politics economics history
and foreign policy and the ideas that
conquered the world covers all of them
should be works of literature written
and clear lively vivid fashion and not
works of science written in a
specialized language intelligible only
to a very few so the reader of the ideas
that conquered the world will find lots
of metaphors a few jokes and no jargon
the second point on which this story
bears is that this is where the person
who is in effect responsible for our
being here in this room comes into the
picture for peace democracy and free
markets were Woodrow Wilson's ideas he
presented them at Paris after World War
one as the formula for organizing the
world in the wake of that terrible
conflict and these three ideas are the
source of Woodrow Wilson's enduring
relevant
to our public affairs as well as to the
ambivalence indeed the sharply polarized
opinions that people continue to hold
about them for Woodrow Wilson did not
succeed in implementing these three
great ideas after World War one the
interwar period was characterized by
anything but peace democracy and free
markets and yet ultimately now in the
21st century as I detail in the book
these ideas have triumphed so Woodrow
Wilson goes down in history at least in
my book as a poor statesman but an
excellent prophet and I say why and how
these are true in the ideas that
conquered the world well to return to
its thesis the second word in this
thesis the triumph of our liberal ideas
is our ideas that is to say who are we
here I mean not just the United States
these three great ideas were invented
primarily in Great Britain and
secondarily in France and so they are
certainly Western in origin but they're
no longer only Western now they are
universal Japan is a market economy even
as Great Britain is India like the
United States is a democracy and this
Universal quality of these three great
ideas is an important source of their
appeal it's not necessary for any
country to side with the United States
on all issues or even on any issue to
embrace these three great ideas it's
perfectly possible to be pro-democracy
and anti-american a certain country in
Western Europe noted for its fashion and
cuisine comes to mind in this regard
well the third qualification involves
the term liberal ideas what do I mean by
that I do not use the term liberal in
the way that it is used in the everyday
discourse of American politics in which
liberals oppose conservatives over
issues such as abortion and taxation
rather I use the term liberal in its
classic original 19th century sense for
liberty in this sense Democrats
Republicans and independents alike in
the United States are all liberals well
the ideas that conquered the world is
divided into three parts the first
involves history the second foreign and
security policies the third politics and
economics and I'd like to say a brief
word about each first history the
purpose of this section is to fit the
present moment into the history of the
last 200 years there's much to say on
this subject but here I'd like to stress
two points in particular first I see
modern history as a battle of ideas
about how to organize and manage the
world in the 19th century that pitted
that battle pitted liberal modern ideas
on the one hand that is peace democracy
and free markets against the traditional
ways that had held sway over most of the
planet for centuries according to which
war if not necessarily desirable was
certainly normal kings and emperors
ruled on the basis of the principle of
heredity and economic life was destined
to be forever stagnant these traditional
ideas lost ground steadily during the
19th century and were swept away by
World War one but in their wake a
different set of ideas opposing
liberalism arose I call these ideas
illiberal ism so as to group together
under a single rubric both fascism and
communism these two 20th century
ideologies differed from each other in
important ways but they did have three
major elements in common both glorified
war both practiced government by
self-appointed dictatorships and both
practiced extensive in the case of
communism almost total government
control
all of Economic Affairs fascism was
defeated in World War two Orthodox
communism in Europe was swept away at
the end of the Cold War leaving the
three great liberal ideas for the first
time without a serious rival and this
leads me to the second point in part one
of the ideas that conquered the world
that I'd like to stress here in part one
I offer a reinterpretation of the Cold
War the Cold War was like the other
great conflicts of the modern period the
Napoleonic Wars at the end of the 18th
and beginning of the nineteenth
centuries and the two world wars of the
20th century all of them were global
struggles the outcome of which
transformed the world but the Cold War
was unlike these predecessor conflicts
in one important way the Cold War was
one not by force of arms but by force of
example it was the success of the West
the success of our liberal political
systems our societies and above all our
economies that were the key to the
collapse of communism and this point is
important for understanding not only the
past but the present and the future as
well for the Western and now Universal
liberal example remains potent the
forces that brought down communism are
still operating they exert a
gravitational pull on the whole world
well the second part of the ideas that
conquered the world is entitled the
invention of peace the main point here
is that in Europe at the end of the 20th
century there arose almost by accident
an answer to an age-old question the
question of how in a world of sovereign
independent states without any world
government to keep order it is possible
to have not just an armed truce which is
after all familiar throughout history
but something deeper and more lasting
genuine peace
the formula for peace at which europe
and the european powers which
emphatically includes the United States
arrived at the end of the 20th century
has two parts both of them involving
armed forces first armed forces in
Europe are configured for defending but
not for attacking territory second all
armed forces in Europe are subject to
transparency according to which every
government can know at every moment just
what forces every other government
deploys and what those governments are
doing with them these two principles
have bred a kind of confidence that
underpins a deeper peace than Europe has
ever known and the key to adopting them
is a cluster of attitudes involving the
use of force that evolved in the West
although not unfortunately as yet
elsewhere over the course of the second
half of the 20th century which I call
war lessness by war lessness I mean a
pronounced principled and widespread
aversion to armed conflict in a chapter
entitled the cure for cancer I described
the origins of what I title the common
security order in Europe and in the
following chapter entitled the most
dangerous place on the planet I assess
the prospects for establishing
comparable security arrangements in the
other part of the world in which a
conflict that could attain global
dimensions could start namely East Asia
now in recent days attention in East
Asia has been focused on the Korean
Peninsula and the prospect of the spread
of nuclear weapons to the regime
controlling the northern part of that
Peninsula this is indeed an important
issue in one with which I deal in the
ideas that conquered the world but the
central issue for the future of East
Asia is the disposition the foreign
policy and the relations with its
neighbors of China here I find good news
and bad news
the good news is that in my judgment
there is only one issue over which China
might begin a war that could embroil
many other important countries and that
issue is the status of Taiwan the bad
news is that at this point there is no
solution in sight to Taiwan status that
is satisfactory to all parties concern I
do not believe that war over the status
of Taiwan is inevitable or even likely
but it is possible and because such a
war could involve two important
nuclear-armed countries the People's
Republic of China and the United States
I call East Asia in general and the
Taiwan Strait in particular the most
dangerous place on the planet now peace
is plainly not universal in the wake of
the Cold War and at the outset of the
21st century how do i account for that
well I begin by dividing the world into
two categories the first category is the
core which consists of the rich powerful
countries of Western Europe North
America and Japan in which new ideas and
new products are invented the core
enjoys unprecedented peace the second
category is the periphery and it
includes almost all other countries the
members of what we call during the Cold
War the third world these are countries
to which new products and ideas diffuse
and this is a part of the world that is
turbulent indeed in some ways more
turbulent in the wake of the Cold War
than during that great global conflict I
find at least two reasons for the
turbulence of the periphery at the
outset of the 20th 21st century one of
which has to do with the Cold War the
other which involves Woodrow Wilson
himself during the Cold War the great
powers the major powers the core powers
including the United States and the
Soviet Union poured resources into the
countries of the periphery because of
their rivalry
in order to keep these countries widths
from siding with the other the
governments of the periphery used these
Cold War generated resources to keep
order often by suppressing their own
populations with the end of the Cold War
and the abatement of great power rivalry
the reason for diverting resources to
the periphery vanished and the resources
dried up cut off from resources from the
core on which they had depended many
governments of the periphery lost their
grip on their societies leading to the
disorder that we have observed over the
last decade and more the second reason
for turbulence in the periphery relates
to one of the shortcomings of these
triumphant liberal ideas for although
these three ideas offer a formula for
most of the important public tasks that
societies have to undertake they do not
offer a foolproof method for deciding
where borders are to be located Woodrow
Wilson did of course offer the world
such a formula and that formula is
national self-determination according to
which every nation should have its own
sovereign state and the world's state
should consist of homogeneous nations
the trouble is as we've learned to our
costs and indeed as was foreseen at the
Paris Peace Conference in 1919 when this
formula was first proposed the world is
not neatly divided into nations around
which clear simple borders can be drawn
and so we have seen in the wake of the
Cold War contested borders everywhere
most notably in the former Yugoslavia as
I say in my opinion the disconnection
between the core and the periphery is
one of the central facts of the world of
the 21st century but to this
disconnection there is one major
exception and this exception is the
subject of a separate chapter in the
ideas that conquered the world there is
one part of the
planet from which emanate real threats
to the core that part is the Middle East
the Middle East is home to the world's
largest deposits of oil the cut off of
which would inflict serious damage on
core countries including our own the
Middle East is also home to regimes that
define their interest in ways
antithetical to those of the west and
the United States and are seeking
weapons of mass destruction to pursue
those interests Iraq is the obvious
example and the Middle East as we learn
to our sorrow and our cost on September
11 2001 is the breeding ground for the
kind of terrorism that can and has
reached North America the solution to
the manifold problems in the Middle East
and in other countries of the periphery
is the establishment in these countries
of peace democracy and free markets what
are the chances that this will happen in
the course of the 21st century that is
the subject of part 3 of my book the
title of this section is the liberal
theory of history a phrase I've coined
to refer to a widely held if seldom
systematically articulated view that
there is a relationship among these
three great liberal ideas that they go
together that one tends to lead to or at
least foster the others put this way
this sounds almost too good to be true
but the fact that something sounds too
good to be true doesn't necessarily mean
that it's not true and in fact in part
three of the ideas that conquered the
world I find considerable evidence in
favor of two propositions the first of
these is that democracies tend to
conduct peaceful foreign policies at
least toward one another this
proposition has been the subject of
considerable research and discussion in
the field of political studies over the
last quarter century I find the
proposition to be true as long as
it is acknowledged but democracy
consists not simply of elections which
are relatively easy to stage but also
and equally importantly of
constitutionalism the rule of law the
protection of individual rights and
rights of minority groups something that
is harder to establish and rarer in the
world the second proposition that lies
at the heart of the liberal theory of
history for which I find considerable
evidence is the proposition that market
economies tend to become political
democracies now there's nothing
automatic about this association this
association is not a law of history like
a law of physics if only because there
are no laws of history like the
invariant laws of physics but the
relationship between free markets and
democratic politics is I find a tendency
a predisposition a matter of both logic
and historical evidence and this means
that perhaps the most important
development in the world at the outset
of the 21st century is the virtually
Universal embrace of free markets indeed
in the book I go so far as to venture
the thought that the free market has
become the most widely popular and
legitimate institution in all of human
history but having said that again two
qualifications are in order first it has
proven especially since the collapse of
Orthodox communism in Europe far more
difficult to conduct to construct
effective working free markets than was
believed during the 20th century the
struggle to conduct working free markets
is the most important piece of public
business in most countries of the world
and specifically it is the most
important piece of public business in
Russia and China to countries whose
economic problems I argue in the book
are more similar than is commonly
recognized and two countries
two countries that receive a
considerable amount of attention in the
ideas that conquered the world the
second qualification is that working
free markets even where they are well
established even where they function
well even for example in the United
States are scarcely without problems so
while I believe that the 21st century
will be the age of the market this does
not mean that the Centurion which we
have embarked will be free of problems
it means rather that if things go well
the problems with which we will have to
deal are the problems that the free
market typically presents and I discuss
these problems in some detail in part 3
of the ideas that conquered the world
well in conclusion two thoughts about
the United States and then one more
general point about the book the United
States is the most important country in
the world in no small part because it is
the united states that bears the
greatest responsibility for sustaining
the global conditions in which peace
democracy and free markets can flourish
about the United States this book has
two contrarians to make there are two
departures from the prevailing wisdom
first the world is now noisily concerned
that the United States is being too
active in the world the term rogue
superpowers sometimes applied to the
conduct of the United States in the
international arena but I believe that
there is an equal danger that the United
States will not be active enough
internationally that this country will
prove too reticent to carry out the
tasks that even those government's most
critical of one or another of America's
foreign policies want this country to
sustain for the sake of global order
throughout the 21st century I say why
this is so in the book the second
departure from the prevailing wisdom has
to do with American power
that power is surely very great and yet
in important ways i believe and argue in
the book that it is irrelevant after all
the most important goal of the united
states in the 21st century is to promote
peace democracy and free markets where
they are not securely rooted above all
in Russia and China for this task the
American the Western and the liberal
example are remarkably unprecedented ly
potent but the actual tools of American
foreign policy namely guns money and
words suggesting that either or both
might be used oh really I believe not of
much use for establishing free markets
and working democracies in a particular
country it is the citizens of that
country who must do the work I
illustrate this point in the book with a
version of the familiar American
lightbulb joke this one goes how many
psychiatrists does it take to change a
lightbulb the answer is none the light
bulb has to want to change itself well
in order to adopt these three great
liberal ideas and the institutions to
which they give rise individual
countries around the world have to want
to do so themselves and have to do it
themselves this book is contrary in' in
a final way and this is my final point
as will be clear from what I've said so
far this is a book whose tone and tenor
is optimistic and for some people
especially some of my colleagues in the
Academy optimism about the future of the
world is not only wrong it's
unacceptable there are some people I've
discovered who will forgive anything but
optimism and so in comments following
talks that I've given about the book and
even in a few reviews of the book most
of which have been extremely favorable
I've glimpsed the following message not
I disagree with you but rather how dare
you say that
to which I respond that I say that
because all the evidence I see supports
the proposition that with all the
problems and difficulties that the world
now has and surely will always have with
all the troubles and dangers that we
face despite all the turbulence the
world is going our way that's my story
and I'm sticking to it thank you thank
you Michael let's turn now to James
Claire felt for his comments to initiate
this the discussion which I hope will
follow Thank You Robin and stuff a
pleasure and be back at the Wilson
Center in my decade a while back and
they spent in Washington DC the Wilson
Center was always a kind of a haven
especially at the noon time when they
had their discussion groups and
presentations and like that something i
really miss being back in the on Long
Island where I'm somewhat more isolated
and you just can't walk across the
street and hear a discussion like this
Michael I thought that was a wonderful
presentation and let me also say this
about this book which I am you seem to
the column I wrote on it a big fan of
but not only is the book challenging and
stimulating for this type of elite
audience that we have here today but I
think the book is so well written and so
clearly written that it also has great
appeal to the type of audience I write
for is a journalist for a mass
circulation newspaper and I think that's
a real accomplishment now let me say I
just got the call two evenings ago
asking me to film in for Pat Moynihan
and that is a breathtaking assignment in
one that I declined to do because
obviously there is nobody who can sit in
or replace Pat Moynihan I covered him as
a senator
I I consider him one of the great men he
is a man that I went to and I still go
to whenever I'm working on an editorial
on a particular problem because he has
great wisdom and insight and I'm just
sorry he can't be with us today and i
also want let me point out that if all
of you are not aware of it we are at the
the Wilson Center which is an
organization that he was instrumental in
helping to create I believe back when he
was in the Kennedy administration so the
fact that he is a senior scholar he's a
lot more than a senior scholar here he's
really one of the key founders of this
wonderful institution and not only that
but he was also instrumental in seen
that this building was built and for
those of you who had trouble finding
where we were going to go I always blame
him for you know has a great interest in
buildings and architecture and like that
it's actually a magnificent building but
it's headed the Public Works Committee
or a member of the public works
committee and a ranking member and
majority member in the Senate he was key
in getting this building built in the
Wilson Center located here now what I'm
going to try to do in the next few
minutes and very quickly so we can get
to the question and answer period is do
what I do for a living which is I'm a
reporter I'm not a scholar and I don't
pretend to be one so let me report to
you that a few months after September
11th I came down here and had lunch with
Pat Moynihan and we walked across the
street by the way if any you've done
this with him as you walk down
Pennsylvania Avenue you get an immediate
lesson in American history in the
history of pennsylvania avenue because
he is also the key person in the
revitalization of pennsylvania avenue
going back to his years were with
President Kennedy and we had lunch and
we started obviously to talk about the
stunning events of September 11th and I
won't even try to
I'm that discussion because as those of
you who had contact with him know that
he will go off on seeming tangents
spinning out in places you never thought
you were going to go in the particular
discussion and then all of a sudden
about three quarters of the way through
were at least for me because I'm
probably a little dense you realize wow
he's right on the mark and so what he
was talking to me about that they was a
slightly different theory and
interpretation of our modern history and
he particularly meant now he had written
his own book about ethnicity in world
affairs and as an explanation for what
we're going to see and it's a wonderful
wonderful impression book but he also
was talking about an article that and
then a book that professor Samuel
Huntington of Harvard had written called
The Clash of Civilizations and Mike I
think it's an interesting point to take
to look at Huntington's thesis and see
how it relates to what you're saying
because basically Huntington said thanks
Cuse me what we face here in the future
is not as optimistic as Michael talks
about but is a fundamental reordering of
conflict not among nations but among in
between cultures and he was fairly
pessimistic in what this meant for the
world and talking to Senator Moynihan
that day who by the way i would put
squarely in the liberal school of
history Rob and I don't think there's
any doubt about that but Moynihan was
very taken with the Huntington argument
and felt that we were in for a very
tough time in the future that this clash
of civilizations was going to if not
overwhelm challenge everything that that
we had accomplished or thought we had
accomplished in the post-cold war period
and clearly when you look at
your chapter on the Islamic challenge
you know that I think there's a tendency
at times to look at al Qaeda and the
Muslim fundamentalism even more hobby
ism that comes out of Soviet Saudi
Arabia and say well that's the exception
it's it's not what Islam is all about
and yet it's it's an oversimplified
explanation in many ways I think because
more I study Islam and I think we've all
been forced to do that the more you
realize that there are some very
fundamental conflicts coming out of this
arm and its role with the state and in
conflict with possibly the ideas of
peace democracy and free markets this is
by no means a small challenge and one
that's going to go away quickly so first
of all I'd like to hear you talk a
little bit about that and how it relates
to you to your theory also I thought
would also be interesting and you made
reference to this there's there is this
sense of American exceptionalism that we
see and i think is reflected very much
in the bush administration's foreign
policy the sense that we know better
we've got it right and we're going to go
do things whether you're going to you
the allies are going to be with us or
not and I think that upsets amount of
people certainly have said many of the
Europeans and there are the bush people
will at least try to take the rhetoric
that you use Michael about peace
democracy and free markets and use it to
bolster their sense of American
leadership and American unilateralism
and I wonder how you react react to that
and then finally if there's still time I
interested to hear a little bit about
where you place yourself in the basic
argument that Rob set out at the
beginning of the discussion between the
realists and and the liberal theories of
history because in
I don't like for almost 20 years now
Mike at one time was known as a leading
proponent of the realist the school and
I think he has evolved and be
interesting to hear I think a little bit
how you're thinking has evolved and why
it's evolved so with that I play my role
as reporter and ask you three questions
but thank you very much James for your
thoughtful comments and I think as the
discussion and falls we would like to
hear Michael's a reaction to that there
are at least two contending big ideas to
complete to explain the past and the
future of international relations at
least the future one we heard in it as I
describe it undiluted form from John
Mayer Chalmers book the tragedy of great
power politics in which he pointed to a
possible rise of China as a pure
competitor the United States and that
that is just the way States operate and
and will will be easily be the case in
the future the other contending big idea
to explain contemporary international
relations is Professor Huntington's the
clash of civilizations of article and
and book which talks about a possible
cleavage in the society that would in
international society which would under
undermine the kind of international
order that you described in your book
but let me you know having Twp those
questions let's turn to the audience
allow them to offer comments or
questions and then give you an
opportunity maybe collect a couple of
them and provide an opportunity for you
to respond we have microphones on the
side which we can pass him yes sir if
speakers could identify themselves
please
don't believe it's amplifying their
thinking is on cartoon face and then one
thing you did not talk about in your
presentation was demographics given a
group of societies that are successful
politically and economically drawing
immigrants from societies that are
marginal on what what is the ultimate
impact on this our people American
Society arguably has always been
rejuvenated by immigration but on the
other hand many of the people who could
richly enriched our lives here might
have made contributions in their
original societies which would have led
to the triumph of free markets and
democracy so my question is are we
reaching a stage where certain societies
have so utterly failed that anyone with
ambition and drive is better advised to
come to the United States and um and
Western Europe rather than to copy or
imitate us at home or are they
essentially seeds of their own original
country's future development I mean
granted individuals fall into both camps
there are people who once they reach the
West View America as the promised land
and even if the streets aren't paved
with gold and there are others like the
lp people who September 11th crowd who
were completely oblivious as to where
they were living other than as a as a
target thank you let's also hear from
Stanley coger
a couple of points first as someone who
agreed about a dozen years ago with your
thesis and wrote about it and change to
become were pessimistic um one of the
things that's impressed me is that the
conflicts are not ideologically profound
i think george orwell had it right when
he said four legs good two legs bad in
under communism it was now culinarian
good capital is bad now you know once
people have that mentality that's all
you need you have conflict it's the
prevalence of that mentality do you look
at people different from you as somebody
from whom you can learn or do you look
upon them as alien and a threat and it's
as simple as that the ideology maybe
appeal to the intellectuals but I think
for most people it's that simple and
second about democracy something I think
we forget Adolf Hitler came to power
under the rules of parliamentary
democracy when he was challenged by
Winston Churchill as being undemocratic
he responded you know I I competed an
election I competed an election in which
the entire German people participated
can mr. Churchill make such a claim and
if you go back to the American Founding
particularly the Constitutional
Convention there was a concern about the
dangers of elective monarchy and when I
look at what happened why why by mar
went bad it seems to me this is a point
of democracy that we haven't focused on
enough this was something that Jefferson
warned about he said first we have to
worry about excessive power in the
legislature but ultimately it's going to
be excessive power in the executive
thank you let's hear from David shambo's
a third question then let Michael
respond and I'm keeping a list Howard
Stephen and gentlemen the back okay
thank you rob I'd like to ask I guess to
if I can one is one question michael has
to do with the relationship between
markets and democracy do you subscribe
to the view that markets invariably
produce democracies or can you have a
market economy without democracy such as
we have today in China much of the
Middle East and indeed many of the newly
industrialized countries of East Asia
which may be
receives as in Singapore Japan but not
in the way that we understand them and
what does that mean for the democratic
piece of thesis if your answer is no you
can have markets without democracies
what does that say about Democratic
peace the second thing I'd like to ask
you about is your view of the
relationship between international
institutions and American foreign policy
as has been raised here Joe and I of
course are using his book very much we
need to work through international
institutions mearsheimer has little use
for international institutions this
administration is ambivalent at best on
international institutions where do you
come down go ahead Michael Merv question
for you that's just a junior might going
again thank you that is a rich array of
questions let me go through them and try
to deal with them each briefly with two
caveats in advance first I can't
possibly do justice to these all of them
extremely important questions or
comments in the brief time that we have
and second I have I think touched on
each of these issues in the book so
those of you here or watching on c-span
who want a greater exposure to my
responses than is available here it is
available in the book let me say
something first about the Huntington
thesis in the clash of civilizations
which is a very powerful statement and
surely captures part of the reality of
the 21st century especially as it
relates to the arab-muslim world but I
think not the dominant trend there are
two major premises of Huntington's
thesis from which I descent first he
sees the basic unit of international
politics in the 21st century as being
the civilization now leaving aside the
much-debated question of how you define
a civilization it's my view that the
major actor in international affairs in
the 21st century as in the 20th will be
the nation-state nations state
are not going to fade away they're going
to continue to be important they're
going to continue to be the major
players in the game of international
politics all of the rules of the game
have changed the second precept of the
Huntington thesis with which I disagree
or which i believe is not the dominant
reality in the world is his view that
these civilizational groups are driven
to conflict he sees that as the basic
driving force of world politics in the
21st century I by contrast see the basic
driving force the undergirding premise
of all of international politics is the
virtually universal desire to get rich
the desire in virtually every society of
individuals to better themselves which
leads governments to feel pressure to
create or at least not to obstruct the
conditions in which prosperity is
possible those conditions it was decided
in the second half of the 20th century
involved creating markets and that I
believe is what has happened in China
now this reality that I described these
basic drives are obviously not present
everywhere and i believe the huntington
thesis does capture part of the world's
reality but only part and the lesser
part as for the ongoing debate between
realism and liberalism as Rob Litvak
rightly discerns I have in a way switch
camps moved across the aisle or at least
part way across the aisle I believe that
realism that is the idea that the
structure of international politics
drives countries toward mutual suspicion
and often conflict is still the reality
in much of the world I believe realism
is in effect the default position for
international politics but as I argue in
chapter 4 the ideas that conquered the
world I believe that the conditions that
breed this age-old pattern of
international politics have been at
least temporarily overcome in Europe for
the first time that is why I entitle the
second part of
this book the invention of peace I
believe that something new different
profoundly important and enormously
hopeful has occurred in Europe although
not elsewhere on the demographic issue
it is certainly true that countries
suffer from brain drains talented people
from countries that are not doing well
that do not have the institutions that
enable them to harness their talents do
have a tendency to move to the Western
core countries there by enriching those
countries and penalizing the countries
that they are leaving there are I think
two hopes that arise from this pattern
for these peripheral countries one is
that these countries will recognize what
is happening and act on it that is to
say that they will organize themselves
in such a way as to make it attractive
for talented people to stay the second
hopeful development is that we do see
signs of diasporas of peripheral
countries in the core organizing
themselves abroad to try to have some
impact on their home countries we see
something of this kind happening among
indian americans in the united states
who are becoming more active in the
affairs of india and let us hope that
they will be effective in helping to
nurture some of the liberal values and
institutions in the country to which
they have come in the country that they
have left on david shambo's points it is
of course true that market economies are
not necessarily democracies but I think
that we see in East Asia a hopeful
tendency of countries with
well-established well-functioning free
markets ultimately to adopt liberal
politics we've seen that pattern in
Taiwan and South Korea in the
Philippines and that is after all the
great hope for China and China is the
great test of the liberal theory of
history the hope and indeed this is the
basis for American and Western policy is
that as China
as a more deeply rooted and better
articulated market economy this will in
this will encourage liberalizing
tendencies in Chinese politics and we
know and as David and his colleagues
have written that china is a vastly
different place even politically today
than it was during the heyday of the
Maoist era and the most important reason
for the changes in Chinese society and
Chinese politics the greater personal
freedom that individual Chinese and joy
is I think the creation of a working
free market there are good reasons good
logical reasons to think that there will
be a spillover effect from markets to
politics after all markets provide a
sphere for individual choice free of
government control when people are
accustomed to acting independently in
the economic sphere it's not
unreasonable to suppose that they will
demand the right to act independently in
the political sphere and working free
markets create a middle class in the
middle class is almost everywhere the
bulwark of democracy so I think we have
reason to hope that over time the
economic trans now underway in China
will nourish favorable political trends
but of course we can't be sure I also
believe that insofar as China becomes
more democratic politically it will be
easier to resolve its conflict with
Taiwan on the one hand it seems to me
likely although not absolutely necessary
that a more democratic China will feel
less intensely about Taiwan because it
will have a democratic source of
legitimacy to replace or supplement the
nationalism on which it now depends
nationalism that leads it to its
particular position on Taiwan on the
other hand it seems to me that the
people in government of Taiwan would be
less nervous about a close association
with a democratic China than they are
with a now steal formerly communist
China but for the liberal theory of
history China is the great test we are
time
short up I'm afraid we'll just be able
to take two more comments and questions
if they please be brief first Howard we
Orta and then Stephen Clarkson Howard we
are two from CSIS in the Wilson Center
Michael I really liked your book a lot
but like all books it's it becomes out
of date at the very time that appears as
compared with when it was written and
let me just raise a couple empirical
things for you wrestle with because I
think you have to deal with these these
problems five or six years ago democracy
as a system had overwhelming support in
virtually every country and throughout
the third world what we're now seeing in
poll after poll after poll is declining
support for democracy as a set of
institutions going down from eighty to
eighty eighty-five ninety percent a
decade ago to fifty sixty five percent
today and in a quite a number of key
countries dropping below fifty percent
or even forty percent for example so
that's one dilemma that you have to deal
with much the same thing as reflected
with regard to free markets for example
where the markets haven't quite worked
out particularly in the third world as
people would have preferred and we're
facing economic crisis in a variety of
countries including most particularly
Argentina and Venezuela let's say who
have the strongest middle classes in all
of Latin America but are precisely the
country's nowadays that are
disintegrating then you have to deal
with the issue that countries mean
different things by democracy than we in
the West do necessarily and have quite
different definitions that may not imply
the same things that you suggest in your
book and finally empirically what we're
getting in an awful lot of third world
countries is not democracy of a liberal
sort but really mixed fused overlapping
systems of corporatism on the one hand
and democracy on the other and free
elections in one regard but
authoritarian controls in other areas of
national life in other words it seems to
me that empirically you've got to deal
with these more recent events as well as
those that look so triumphant at the
time that you were writing and and it
needs some updating thank
and final comment Stephen Clarkson thank
you this fall is on in a way from that
last question accepting your thesis that
these three ideas have have conquered
I'm curious about your analysis of how
you expect them to continue to prevail
do you see them as a kind of Holy
Trinity of self reinforcing
self-regulating system account with the
kind of invisible hand continuing that
the situation or do they need a hegemon
to enforce them and if that's the case
what happens to the system if the
hegemon itself doesn't accept the
premises and is not itself ruled
democratically by the international
community's views that last question
feeds into one of the critiques most
recently articulated by John I came
bearing foreign affairs about and
contained in his book called after
victory in which he sort of makes the
argument about American power being
embedded in international institutions
and therefore less threatening to others
and that over playing our hand so to
speak in the current era could undermine
that perception and have negative
consequences for the structure that you
laid out uh well again these are
important points good questions there
isn't time to respond adequately so let
me respond in adequately first on the
issue of the role of the United States
because that is the issue that the
number of these questions raised it is
true that there is a danger that the
United States will overplay its hand
that it will be regarded as a kind of
rogue elephant trampling through the
international system the United States
could go too far and will know that the
United States has gone too far when
other countries begin rearming and
forming coalition's to check the United
States but for all the grumbling that
we've heard and here every day about
American foreign policy nothing like
this has even begun to happen and I
think on this issue
we should watch what other countries do
not pay so much attention to what they
say complaining about the United States
is the god-given right of every country
and every government in the 21st century
but thus far I don't see any sign that
other countries are so dissatisfied with
the role that the United States is
playing that they're about to do
anything about it and I certainly don't
think that the prospect of the forcible
removal from power of Saddam Hussein in
Iraq will be enough to galvanize this
so-called anti hegemonic coalition
that's why i say as i as i mentioned in
my prepared remarks that to me an equal
danger is that the united states will
fail to play a sufficiently robust role
in the world odd as that may sound at
this juncture in our history it seems to
me that american reticence is at least
as great a danger to these three great
liberal ideas as an overbearing american
foreign policy now on the subject of
declining support for democracy and free
markets here let me make just two points
first democracy and especially free
markets are not without problems and
indeed free markets because they are as
the great Austrian American economist
Joseph Schumpeter called them exercises
in creative destruction because they
destroy even as they create the workings
of free markets especially the effective
working of free markets is bound to
create a backlash there will always be a
backlash against free markets wherever
they are established and the politics of
countries such as ours will revolve
around the battles between the winners
and the losers or rather they will
involve the battle to decide how to deal
with how to cope with how to compensate
people for the destructive effects of
free markets that is inevitable that is
the center of our politics if we are
lucky a second point about
dissatisfaction with democracy and free
markets is I think relevant here
one of the great strengths that these
ideas and the institution's to which
they give rise possess that I emphasized
in the book is that for the first time
since they were introduced there are no
alternatives to them however
dissatisfied people in Brazil or
Argentina or Indonesia or South Korea
maybe with the workings of the free
market they have nowhere else to go that
was emphatically not the case during the
worst crisis of free markets and
democracies in the modern period namely
the 1930s when capitalism seemed to fail
fascism and communism offered
alternatives and they seemed promising
alternatives at the outset they worked
for a while those experiments ended in
disaster but that wasn't readily
predictable when they were first tried
well at the outset of the 21st century
there's nothing else in sight there's no
other model that seems plausible
evidence of this is the response by the
East Asian countries at the end of the
1990s to the financial crisis that
afflicted many of them the financial
crisis inflicted severe economic damage
on these countries worse than anything
the Western countries had experienced
since the Great Depression so if ever
there was an occasion for these
countries to turn sharply against the
free market and try another form of
economic organization then the late
1990s was that occasion and yet no such
thing happened instead Indonesia South
Korea Thailand and the other countries
concluded that the solution to the
problems that free markets present is
better free markets there's nowhere else
to go and unless and until an
alternative model for organizing
politics and economics is presented one
that seems to have some chance of
success for all the difficulties that
they present the world will be stuck
with these liberal institutions and
ideas thank you very much Michael before
a journey to the reception in the
adjacent room the boardroom let me
mention an upcoming event on next
Tuesday februari fourth there'll be an
event in this room at 5pm
with former Deputy Secretary of Treasury
Stuart eisenstadt who will be discussing
his new book written in part at the
Woodrow Wilson Center entitled imperfect
justice which is a chronicle of his
leadership of the effort by the United
States government to negotiate
reparation payments for Holocaust
victims in the 1990s at the outside I
said it was particularly apt to that a
meeting on this particular book take
place in this building this official
memorial to Woodrow Wilson this has been
a rich discussion of these important
ideas that and the debate about those
ideas that are driving our contemporary
international political scene so Michael
thank you so much for your excellent
presentation likewise James goad l33
commentary thank you all for joining us
Michael mandal bombs book is the ideas
that conquer the world peace democracy
and free markets in the 21st century
it's published by public affairs online
at public affairs books calm